text nochmal hier obst ich bin direkt
schon wieder weg hallo ich meine lieben
freunde herzlich willkommen zu einer
weiteren folge von den minecraft fake
sie die nicht gestern am dienstag kamen
sondern heute am mittwoch dass sie ganz
einfach daran weil ich jetzt den ganzen
tag unterwegs war und ich deswegen zeit
hatte das poste ich auch immer auf
twitter wenn ich mal keine zeit aber
hier folgt bedauern nicht alle sondern
nur ein paar tausend von euch also macht
dass er jedenfalls habe ich mir gedacht
okay kommen reiß dich zusammen hat die
folge wenigstens noch am mittwoch heute
hoch und ich hab es hingekriegt dank
eurer kleinen tricks wie immer vor ihrer
facts folge die sachen die ebel zusendet
werden denn diese folge drangenommen
also die serie besteht komplett aus
euren e mails an meinem elcon crafter
gmail.com da könnt ihr mir sachen den
schreiben steht auch nochmal unten in
der beschreibung drin
und mitten in diesem video werdet ihr
wieder ein geräusch finden welches ihr
mir in die kommentare schreiben könnt
wenn ihr das ganze erwartet und dann ist
es eure chance in den nächsten video
eventuell erkannt zu werden in sodom ich
meine nicht erkannt zu werden sondern
genannt zu werden also wenn ihr das
geräusch was irgendwann in dieser folge
auftritt richtig in den kommentaren
errät erwartet dann werdet ihr in der
nächsten folge genannt weil das jetzige
geräusch aus der letzten folge wurde von
free games lpr raten wären nämlich
gesagt hat okay du hast dein iphone
einfach aus gemacht und das stimmt aber
ich würde sagen wir fangen direkt an mit
den minecraft und zwar hat mir alle so
toll oli zugesendet hague kräftig haben
minecraft ein paar interessante fakten
gefunden
ich nehme allerdings nur einen davon
weil es unfair gegenüber den ganzen
anderen wäre wenn man eingibt / fedcon
crafter 1 1.000.000 205 50 wird man sehr
schnell als effekt der in game name wenn
ihr free games lp hsg quasi free games
lp 1
dann eine 1 millionen und eine 255 ich
nehme jetzt einfach mal in milch mit
weil das ein ganz normaler effekt ist
der euch hier angezeigt wie jeder wie
jeder andere auch
das ist ein effekt von crafter eine
millionen 255 lukas so blöd ducati 1
vergessen das ist effekt in game dann
eine 1 und dann die eine million dann
die 255 also ist das ganze so ein game
perfecta neuer in game nahm dann eine 1
dann eine eine million und dann die 255
und jetzt sehen wir schon als das ganze
komplett anders aus ich verrate euch
dann auch mal was das ganze macht und
zwar wer die extra extremst extrem sehr
extrem schnell ich drücke einmal auf das
weh und ich bin direkt vor mir auf der
stufe ich drücke noch einmal drauf bin
auf der nächsten
ich will nicht wissen ich zeige jetzt
mal was passiert wenn ich wäge drückt
halte hierfür kurzem 11 5 modus zack ich
bin hier da hinten ist meine teststrecke
mache ich das ganze noch mal ich habe
hier eine unendliche geschwindigkeit
läuft mal kurz daraufhin direkt von den
nächsten block ich habe nur einmal kurz
drauf gedrückt und bin auf einmal direkt
zur seite gesprintet
vielleicht noch mal hier ich bin direkt
schon wieder weg also das ist richtig
richtig krass wie schnell man einfach
ist das ganze kriegt man weg indem er
etwa milch trinkt dann seid ihr auch
direkt schon viel näher dran und das ist
auf jeden fall als es ist zwar einfach
nur ein befehl aber einfach mal wenn ihr
richtig schnell von a nach b wollt macht
das einfach anstatt zu fliegen danke an
die hat mich nicht warum ich irgendwie
ne brille und eine capcom auf habe ich
ja mal vergessen denn 3d film eine kette
grad auf meinem pc drauf von daher hab
ich doch durchsetzt ja genau ihr seid an
dem moment angekommen wo ich euch jetzt
das geheimnisvolle geräusche nennen wer
oder was ihr mir jetzt und in die
kommentare schreiben können mit euren
kleinen fleißigen fingern also schwingt
eure finger schon mal auf die tastatur
und navigiert eurem aus in die
kommentarbox weil jetzt kommt das
geräusch was eben in die kommentare
schreiben könnte
da ist es so dass ist das geräusch wenn
ihr es kennt dann schreibt seine
kommentare und dann würde ich sagen
eventuell seid ihr ja im nächsten video
in einer erwähnung mit dabei der zweite
effekt wurde mir zugesendet von daniel
von die alle stalker 2 2 2 und zwar mein
daniel wenn man einen pfeil auf einen
umgekehrten bogen schießt kann man nicht
mehr auf sammeln darf habe ich mir
einfach mal einen bogen und 64 pfeile
geholt und ihr seht schon wenn ich hier
weiter darauf schieße dann
treten die es immer sogar ein bisschen
später auf das liegt aber irgendwann mal
im shader oder an dem update oder
irgendwie sowas soll ich glaub ich hab
sogar einen fall da unten rein
geschossen hat kann ich sicher
jedenfalls sind jetzt fünf eile drin
moment gekommen ist wie es nicht wir
sind jetzt acht häuser hier sind ja
sogar sechs pfeile und wenn ich hier
drüber laufen ist ja eigentlich so dass
ich die aufsammeln irgendwie aber gerade
nicht ist auch wenn ich jeden fall hin
schieße moment warten ganz kurz wegen
dem grafik bugs dass er wiederkommt soll
da kann ich wieder aufsammeln
das liegt nicht daran dass ich irgendwie
im game findet also ich kann auch ein
game und null gehen und hier darüber
laufen
mittlerweile regnet einfach in jeder
minecraft werkzeuge die ich aufnehmen
das ist richtig traurig jeden fall zur
wahl stehen geblieben ich habe die
pfeile auf den umgang hatten burgen
geschaut auf dem umgekehrten boden
geschossen mit meinem bogen und ich kann
diese feier herzlich aus sammeln das
liegt nicht an den gamer oder ihnen
sonst etwas anders liegt einfach an
diesem umgang hat einen bogen boden denn
ich kann die sachen jetzt jemand bauen
beispielsweise die mal ganz gut wieder
zurück in die gerne und mit ihr das seht
ich so jetzt kann ich die nehmen
beispielsweise auch wieder einsammeln
weil die pfeile durch das abbauen hier
auf das eis fallen und dann kann ich die
wieder einsammeln als ich wollte
beispielsweise mit den ab kann ihnen
jetzt einsammeln wenn ich dann
allerdings darauf schieße kann ich den
dementsprechend dann nicht einsammeln
danke an dich daniel ist ein cooler
fällt der nächste weg wurde zugesendet
von lala langweilig also cookie crafter
1999 und zwar meint er oder sie ich
denke sie aber eine doppelte farbiges
glas über beide tun normal wenn ein blog
bei der tres lässt sich ja nicht öffnen
bei glas schon und zwar hab ich jetzt
beispielsweise mal normales wird darüber
gepackt ihr seht kann ihn nicht öffnen
hier habe ich beispielsweise jetzt mal
die wir das überhaupt quartz blogger ich
hier genau truhe öffnen habe ich glas
darüber kann ich die tore öffnen das ist
eigentlich genau so ein solid blog wie
die ganzen anderen blöcke auch
allerdings kann man kann sich dadurch
irgendwie kiste öffnen dass es irgendwie
sehr sehr komisch die denken so nur wenn
man durch das durchdrücken kann kann
auch eine kiste rein ich meine
theoretisch ja ihr könnt nicht durch
eure zimmer durchschlagen
aber dementsprechend müsste eigentlich
eure glaswand durch ein fenster
durchschlagen können und bei farbigen
glas geht das ganze aus dass es egal ob
wir das glas nehmen oder ob ich
theoretisch ein stuhl des glas niemals
die ganze zeit aber danke an dich lala
bzw cookie crafter 1999 ist gut zu
wissen zu guter letzt noch ein effekt
von morina und zwar dann kann dich
lorina erstmal und zweimal hat sie mir
ein tolles bild geschickt wenn ich den
ganzen sachen so anordnen
also ich muss nicht unbedingt so
anordnen ich kann das auch irgendwie
diese beiden sachen hier beispielsweise
mal vertauscht nummer ich dass man
ebenso das habe ich nur so angehört und
damit er das besser sehen könnt jetzt
wieder thematisieren was jetzt wieder
heile damit das besser aussieht
die stadt bleibt wir sehen hier ganz
normale half steps und ihr kennt das ja
wenn ich zb den und den habe also
eichenholz stufen und ich will die
nebeneinander setzen dann setzt er
welche drauf dann habe ich so normal
blog
wenn ich jetzt wieder mit der mittleren
maustaste draufdrücken dann bekomme ich
ja den bock ins inventar und dann habe
ich den quasi wieder aber nicht als
ganzen block sondern immer noch als die
stufen
das besagt quasi auch wenn ich zwei mal
die gleichen stufen zusammen mache
bekomme ich noch nicht den block zurück
sondern die einzelnen stufen da man
nicht den block dadurch zurück bekommt
müsste es ja eigentlich da noch sein
dass sich zwei stufe beieinander packen
kann und dementsprechend auf welche
stufe ich von den beiden dann gucke die
bekomme ich dann zurück allerdings geht
das nicht bzw noch nicht die wollen dass
bald glaube ich mal einführen also ich
wäre dafür dass sie das mal langsam
einführen dass sich beispielsweise wenn
ich jetzt hier hier möchte ich jetzt zum
beispiel okay
bis hierhin geht man haus so zweieinhalb
blöcke hoch und dann geht es noch mal
zweieinhalb meter hoch mit diesem
material weiter wenn ich das dann
allerdings darauf setzte ist das so
alles in ordnung oder ich zeige euch das
mal ganz so zweieinhalb meter hoch und
jetzt will ich noch mal zweieinhalb
lücke aber dann sieht das ganze so aus
da ist quasi so ein hohlraum obwohl das
beides holz ist und einfach nur eine
andere farbe ich finds halt so ein
bisschen traurig dass das ganze nicht so
richtig klappt also den hier kann ich
jetzt natürlich schon hier so drauf
setzen das klappt nämlich nur wenn das
das gleiche ist genauso gleich ist das
auch bei cobblestone beispielsweise wenn
ich cobblestone auf dieses steins die
gesetze die sogar aus cobblestone
gemacht sind geht das auch nicht sondern
er geht da oben drauf finde ich ein
bisschen traurig aber ist er halt auf
jeden fall platz verdient und diesen
facts video und natürlich auch schon
sagen dass wir damit den jetzigen
mittwochs nächste woche müssten sie
eigentlich wieder am dienstag kommen ich
werde ein bisschen was vor drehen weil
ich ja in den urlaub fahren werde
und sonst würde ich sagen ich wünsche
euch noch einen schönen tag sehr sehr
schönen abend wenn es euch gefallen hat
was doch bitte einmal ich da effektiver
steht in den kommentaren bzw in der
beschreibung und würde ich sagen